I got Harbor when he was nine weeks old.
And he used to trip on his ears walking.
And down the stairs, he used to roll down the stairs because he would trip on them.
And he still sometimes trips on them but not as much as he did when he was just a little pup.
I sometimes play with his ears to make kids or friends laugh.
We put them up on his head like Princess Leia.
Or cover his face with an ear if he's napping.
When Harbor and I are walking down the street, almost every person we pass...
...says something about his ears.
I've had a lot of people take photos of him, strangers on the street.
I've had garbage trucks pull over...
...and the garbage man get out of the driver seat and jump down to pet him...
...and meet him because of his ears.
And I don't even see his ears anymore, most days I forget how really oddly long they are.
It's really fun to be the owner of a Guinness World Record holder.
The credit goes to my nephew, who started the process of being here today and...
...his proud owner. I think it's a riot.